[Music]  police found a blood-soaked rug in the  trunk of a car  driven by two teen murder suspects that  is one of the new details revealed in  court transcripts obtained by the i-team  sixteen-year-old sierra halseth and her  boyfriend 18-year-old aaron guerrero  charged with murdering her father daniel  halseth and then trying to cover it up  police say they have cell phone video of  the teens talking about the murder  surveillance video of them buying saws  and bleach  and of course that rug daniel halsett's  mother and an  ex-wife told the grand jury that he sent  a friend  to check on daniel when they couldn't  reach him and that's when she found the  crime scene  we're going to have more on this for you  coming up here at six o'clock